new report shows people who already had
the coronavirus getting it again in
South Korea 116 patients who recovered
from kovat 19 have tested positive a
second time does this mean the virus can
reactivate or was it never actually out
of the system dr. mark Siegel was here
dr. Siegel what does this mean for
immunity well first of all I want to
reassure people that I believe that in
the vast majority of cases once you've
had kovat 19:00 you're likely over it
and have antibodies and you can fight it
off again for a period of time if we
base it on SARS which is a very similar
virus from 2003 that period of time
would be a couple of years but Brian we
don't have all the information yet and
the people in South Korea I'll put forth
what you already said maybe they never
got over it
maybe those patients had an immune
problem where they couldn't develop an
immunity or maybe they didn't develop
enough of what we call neutralizing
antibody that's a word you've never
heard before but that's what scientists
are looking for are you developing the
kind of antibodies that neutralize the
virus that prevent it from ever giving
you another infection that's the basis
of the vaccine right there that they're
working on neutralizing antibodies we
don't have the complete science on it
yet Brian but I think in the vast
majority of cases when you're over this
you're not going to get it again
what is the most encouraging thing you
hear and from what company when it comes
to the vaccine well I think the idea
that the moderna vaccine is already in
entering the end of Phase one clinical
trials productive out you I spoke to
about this the other day it's going to
get into Phase two very soon and it
looks like it's hitting the target that
it's really working they're very
optimistic about it but it's not only
the moderna vaccine some of the big
pharmaceuticals like Johnson & Johnson
are getting involved in Novartis it's
getting involved other major players are
going to be involved in this Santa Fe so
we'll see where we end up but it's going
to take a while because they have to
give it to a lot of people make sure
that it's effective and then the
manufacturing process Brian costs at
least
million dollars from the beginning to
the end so a lot of money has to be
involved right but you're gonna make a
lot of money too because you know if you
do this you have 180 countries and every
continent that's gonna want to order
from your company your Bob but dr.
Siegel I watched you last night with
Tucker you really thought this COFF was
it would have been the corona virus so
you took the test on camera it was a 15
minute test and we got the answer before
his show was over what was it like it
was nerve-racking because I wanted to
make the point that I like everyone else
has a cough we think we have it and some
of us do have it some don't and that's
why I really want the rapid test to be
more available not just the test I took
on camera last night I actually had a
really great laboratory pathologist come
all the way down from Boston to give me
that test in full garb you saw that
negative within 15 minutes dramatic
during the show but now I'm gonna have
my antibodies tested Brian to our first
point to see if I could have been
exposed to it previously that will
reassure me even more if I actually have
immunity to it or I have an antibody to
it that's on the road to immunity or
that I never got it we need everybody to
know that we're you this thing is so
contagious did you get it were you
exposed to it are you over it those are
the key questions now so dr. Siegel what
I get when I walk around and everyone
says this everyone's got the same
question I want to find out if I had it
I'll give plasma if I have immunity for
it and when can I get the quick test
what do you say when people ask you
these very fundamental questions I think
we need a marshaling out of that of that
rapid test that you saw me show last
night that test there's a only 18,000 of
them in the country they can only do
four per hour per machine so I think we
need a big rollout and either Abbott or
other companies have to give us that
more of that rapid test that's the test
called point of care do you have it now
the antibody test Brian there's a
different problem which is we need to
develop accuracy there's 70 different
companies that are in labs that are
trying to get approval for those
antibody tests we need a standard one
at least a few different companies
narrow it down to the ones that tell us
the most about what your chances of
immunity are and get that to everyone
the NIH is currently doing a study of
10,000 people to see how far kovat 19
has spread into communities the
antibodies are the way to tell that the
blood test I took last night I'll have
the answer today I'll know if I was
exposed to this or not I need everybody
to know that absolutely dr. Siegel
thanks so much appreciate it
thank you Brian